(upbeat music)
- [Narrator] Two words,
snail slime, snail slime.
Snails love their own slime,
which is actually their mucus.
It helps them defy gravity
and move at a snail's pace.
Bad cliché.
But humans also love snail slime
for its nutrient-rich properties.
This began thousands of
years ago when ancient Romans
and Greeks gave snails free
rein to roam their faces.
No more redness, no more wrinkles
for our classical ancestors.
(speaking foreign language)
That is kinda off topic,
Simone, but now that you're here,
I think we should segue
to your introduction.
(speaking foreign language)
He's being modest.
Simone is an inventor and a snail savior.
Before he invented his snail
slime extraction machine,
the only way to collect mass
quantities of snail slime
resulted in the snail's
death, not anymore.
(speaking foreign language)
We begin in the fields.
After munching for 14
months, snails are plucked,
washed, and brought to Simone's
machine, the Muller One.
Sidebar, snails secrete
slime for three reasons:
to move, out of stress, and for pleasure.
Simone calls his machine a spa for snails
because it pleasures
them with a secret spray
to the point that they
secrete a lot of slime.
(speaking foreign language)
If you don't talk metric, I'll translate.
That's as much as seven pounds
of slime from one batch.
After that, the slime is
extracted, dehydrated,
rehydrated, and then refined
here for use in cosmetics.
Here it is being bottled, and
then it's off to your face.
(speaking foreign language)
- Best slime in the world.
- [Narrator] Simone,
if being bold is wrong,
we don't want to be right.